work on your game and focus you get the
win on Thursday and now you've got games
in succession two in New York and then a lot
at home here's the S away Marty bre away and
lolan got a glove on that gate blade is sitting
in the corner here's the great backhand pass by
Tavaris just right on the backand of martyr
the first shot of the game a tough one for
lanolin but look at how aggressively he was out
arner knew he was getting pressure there by L
he'll curl inside the line drops it off Morgan
Riley looking for a shooting lad in front and
that went off a SK wide as Yosi was watching
his old teammate Kelly AR cook in front Doby
and linol able to close down the AR see the
Nashville collapsing back into their own Zone
and then unable to make a play a turnover in the
corner and a smart play as puszi with his head
up finds doy cutting to the net you can see the
reaction with a game tomorrow night in Montreal
he gets the spot on the bench tonight you imagine
you'll see him tomorrow six start of the gear for
loln and sharp and that one deflected off his
Pad action for Samson off hasn't played in the
last five leaf games but Leaf's unable to clear
here's glass getting the pass through there's
a good first stop fors off that aing pass picked
off by gregger got David k shooting and a rebound
Reeds unable to find it and now linnan covers
up with Noah Gregor swinging that over back to
trenin and Marner there defensively for Toronto
gave it away and sets it off with another stopper
another chance of Luke Shan hit a leg with that
try it goes to sizin Roman Yosi holds on and now
forbord banned on that gets it back again for
front SS it off point flank stop Colton siss
original play of Bobble by forsberg but he keeps
it alive and look at as assistance just popped out
playing in the bumper spot to now David campaway
short-handed for Toronto that's a couple of tough
stops for Samson up early yeah he was deep in
his net there cuz he was worried about a pass
across the scene but a quick quick reaction and
then good support in front to clear the rebound
out of Harm's Way the OC sweeps it around forb
let it go it's going to slide all the way back
and a break away it's no a trigger and Lon with
his second Breakaway stop in this opening period
Samson off able to make the play nqu goes after
y Kirk a nice little support pass but Greer's
got to get that one up and over the pad he had
the right idea going from backand to forehand
one shot on goal on the power play leads back
at full strength but Nashville continues with
some momentum and a block off Iron by kri a his
ears might be ringing as that one fired right
off the CR here's Ben was six hits five block
shots on Thursday at 18 minutes for Toronto in
the back line turn over here neander off the
crossfire behind the net it's Lankin and who
turns this one over he gets some help in front
as well look at Luke Shen trying to get down
LOL scored at a 57 goal a season Pace on home ICE
since coming into the league back in it's Matthew
KN tight angle throw it to L stop KN on a great
power move didn't get a shot on goal but lots
of good action here's Matthew Knight pulling
that one AC crou oh Matthews ws and that off
a stick into the corner Riley again tamarus down
low chopping at it knee Lander follows over to n
drops it off for jillin doy loose on this near
side yarn coat back to Timmons doy waiting but
it's a shot right go The Rebound in front Foria
wax still loose clear away from the front of the
net play and we remain without a goal here
in Toronto Luke Jin that's knocked down good
stick there and here goes yard coach against
his former team with a shot blocker Away by
lincolin Conor kimmons nice pass
in the middle David C through C
scors goals in backto back for David
K make a change and he just comes flying off
the bench as is he got a fresh body a quick
little turn up and how about this pass take
the tape splits the middle and then lyan has
been so effective at coming out on the quick
shot instead this is one where you have the
advantage with that speed and the pressure
behind you of MCD all over your shoulder the
cender is going to be a little bit more passive
he's down early and Camp shows great patience
and hands backand to the forehand lifts it up
and over the glove Predators looking for a late
second Peri push but Matthews has other ideas
straight down the middle neander back Matthews
scor 17th of the year for Austin Matthews
and now you got a give and go once you get
the speed through the middle of the ice
watch Matthews takes it around the stick
with Yosi gets it to the outside and good job
of Matthew is not going by didn't stop on the
net but stayed with it as it deflected
off the Stick of Yosi the toe of the
goenda net it's been hard to bust through the
Nashville defense there's a no back shot off
the post and open up the passing Lane here's the
one that did get through as Novak got his head
up through the screen there of leis and Samson's
reaction was just hearing the bell and looked to
his left and was pretty happy to see the puck no
back plays it out and doy got hit with the stick
there but Novak that was the follow through as
you mentioned he was clearing the puck out so
no penalty great play by doy in front yard Coke
and there'll be a penalty what a great take of
the pass by Dolby to set this up now you don't get
it in deep and there's a little area pass by doy
nice job by lancin and davaris turns it over back
in is Ryan O'Reilly to the back hand SS it off
the Stop and got pumped there by O'Reilly on the
way through with a chance to get Nashville on the
board some on benw another stretch gets
it to Martyr to tamarus fired that right
off the logo hery with it put it in front
sarus with the strip marner's on it carner
tarus backand Lincoln and stopped it Colton
szz three short-handed goals and naner got
a stick on that and turns it leaves back
on the attack KN ler Matthew scores number
18 and it's a power play goal for Toronto three
guys going offensively for the Predators now you
got some tired bodies and how about this shot
just a quick release as he got the goal taker
sliding across but Matthews with the quick
look goes five hole Taris with the bump bump
pass neander shoot the passes in the cross early
and that's a go scor goal you know I think the
goenda to get it back to Yosi and Martyr
chopped it by him and out really good
aggressive play there attacking as yarrow
took it away as bro after making the BL and
short HED goal and it's B under the Toronto
that one wasn't close a quick up with a good
stick to open up the lane and a fresh body of
GRE is going to win that skating battle it's
dumped in by Ryan Reeds and the fans saluting
Ilia samsonov who will post his 11th career
shutter